this is not a right-angle triangle and
they slowed its current form but at a
different in of a sudden okay in order
to make it clear what's going on here I
just need to adjust that ever so
slightly okay now I have a right angle
triangle I can form a right angle
triangle I don't know like this one it
won't be like this for a lot of a circle
anymore but I can form a right angle
triangle with the sides behave like this
that give me this Pythagorean theorem in
this particular ratio so draw with me a
right angle trailer just a simple one
like
okay now because I've got X weight on
the left right and then how about 1 1
squared + y squared on the right okay
what that means is in hell if fictional
right angle triangle x squared what X is
which side which side isn't a coin to
permit it's the hypotenuse is it not
it's the biggest side and these two
other the sums of the squares of the
small side that means X is over here and
then if some arbitrary sense that means
I'm going to have a 1 and a y on the
other two sides
okay there our next step is a bit
arbitrary right but we've done this as
mathematicians just so we have a bit of
consistency and the math does end up
being slightly simpler if I put feeder
up here I really could put theater in
either spot it doesn't matter if I put
theater up there I can get some
relationships some trig relationships
out of this just like I got out of that
lining you're trying to plan what
relationships I'm gonna get okay so I
can say cos theta equals 1 on X but I'm
trying to get towards parametric
equations right I try to hit X&Y so I
need to take reciprocals here do you see
that right so really I'm gonna say x
equals sec theta agreed so that's good
so now I've got a on a relationship I
can print here how about Y what we have
anything to get a relationship with
treatment with one I probably one
related to one I want to mix it in with
the X the whole point of parametric
equations is a separate X and one huh
right so I would relate these two and
the ratio our truce is opposite and
adjacent which is 10 so I was saying 10
theta equals opposite on adjacent right
does that make sense
so Y is just 10 do
does this make sense now you have a look
at this is this going to check out
second theater in ten feet up is it
going to check out here and the answer
is absolutely because SEC squared minus
10 squared is equal to 1
really okay just like you saw before
with this one the simpler version all I
need to do to get over here R is to say
well I need to scale it by this amount
for X I need to scale it by that amount
for why does that make sense so I'm
gonna have a sec and B tan fina as my
parent equations know one last there is
there's a bit of problem when we look at
the domain for theatres remember we said
they could just be easily like now this
in theory it could work but really it's
kind of a poor choice when you have a
look at the function that you're dealing
with because what I bought secondly
you're in tanking you're like where do
you want them to exists right think
about this what does the graph look what
do the guys have you done look like
prisons with 60 oh yeah this right he's
um he's cause right so you can see up
until here it exists right see you like
okay at that point I'm going to get a
vertical asymptote so when I draw in
safety that's going to point this and
why this right g3 I think it going up so
good sorry
is that okay they have a look at this
right this is okay but it's a little bit
messy because now I've got like parts
that overlap like not to 2 pi into big
groups so therefore again by convention
and
deal with the different kind of symmetry
that the hyperbola has rather than going
around in a circle like it makes sense
for a circle or an ellipse instead we
say let's start from here deal with the
positive side up here the first and
second quadrants and they still with the
third and fourth quadrants separately so
we go from naught to PI and we also hear
from your turn negative pi so I guess
doing that in order we would say it has
negative time now again in theory they
could have and I've got some
discontinuities in there PI over 2 and
negative plan to this guy and this guy
but you cannot avoid the destruction
unit there of always going to just come
to do these on a shape like the
hyperbola
now why do we use these what was the
point I'm like boy does this seem
complicated as competitors and the idea
is that for instance if you have a look
at a shape here right they are going to
be a whole bunch of points that behave
in concert together I'll give you a very
simple example there's a whole bunch of
pairs of points on the hyperbola where I
could say as an example the tangents are
going to be parallel some raisins open
tremendous before is the reason why
grating is a poor choice of parameter
right a bigger tree line there so that
might be the tangent and it's gonna have
a corresponding one somewhere over here
like so okay now they're not the only
ones there's an infinite set of other
points that will still do this parallel
thing and I keep on moving and the key
is if I want to move around understand
how these two points relate to each
other and angle makes perfect sense to
make a comparison between these two I
mean in this example can you kind of see
what's the difference between the
English
look if I do that from the origin if I
go up to he you have a look at that
angle and if I go over the key to the
other point you have a little bit of an
angle
what's the relationship they are
supplementary aren't they
okay so just in one fell swoop we can
see a create algebraic relationship
between those two it's very obvious to
see provided you have a parameter to
talk about it right now the downside is
the algebra ends up being substantially
worse for example we should come around
I'll show you in a minute
I'm to remember there was this new
suspension to prove that for one focus
to another that distance there always is
to a do you remember that question now
there's a hard way to do it and there's
an easy way algebraically the hard ways
we parameters it's like 10 lines of hard
algebra a much more beautiful way would
be like this watch so you've got a
director term here and you also have a
directories over here grief now I've got
here say for instance I guess
and the stash that you've got P s and P
and staffs do agree with that but by
definition because in all conic sections
you have this relationship right like
that's the relationship that makes it
work and you put different values where
you get to collect therefore like where
are these guys on this diagram well this
is PS - hey D - is very here right this
is the corresponding directions and then
P days regular TV is gonna be over here
do you agree with that but hold on a
second what are the equations of these
two lines the director says right this
is x equals negative a on me and x
equals a on it right so what is this
total distance eat some visit aione and
there's another a on e so therefore that
total distance pd + pd - it goes to a
1/8 I don't want PD on PD - I want PS
plus PS - right the difference between
those two is a factor all so if you put
an e outside there you get rid of that a
and look that there is the S Plus P as
that now that's a beautiful elegant and
simple proof right if you go this path
it's like I said it's uh it's worse and
that's as good as it gets
ok so you can see you have to be a bit
clearer about this you don't just use
these blamin you have to know the times
where it's and this comes in practice
where it makes so much more sense to go
to the parabola versus when you don't go
to the kremlin right
so in colleagues in general you just
have so many pilots to answer your
question and you have to know which ones
most efficient and that comes